folks it is joe derosa from the taste
buds podcast please come see me live
i've got dates coming up in philadelphia
in march i'll be at the south by
southwest festival also in march i'm
also going to be at the creek in the
cave in may and then i will be in fort
myers at comedy fort in june and then
there's a bunch of other dates and stuff
coming up go to joedarosainfo.com
so you can get all the information about
links to ticket sales and show times and
all that sort of thing and then joey
roses in nyc come out and see us we're
open
many days a week we're open for many
hours in those days and it's an awesome
bar social club hang out and we sir we
serve awesome awesome sandwiches so come
see us if you want the info and you're
in town joeyrosesnyc.com
what's up guys going to give you some
tour dates here detroit and pittsburgh
february 11th and 12th we have second
shows they are they are almost sold out
but there's still some tickets left
albany and dc february 18th and february
19th still some tickets left to that
albany show there's two shows uh madison
and chicago february 26th and february
27th i'll be at the barrymore theater
and the vic
nashville lacrista stefano playing the
ryman on march 11th the next day i'll be
in chattanooga on march 12th i'll
reschedule reschedule burlington to may
13th also a rescheduled san diego and
los angeles i will be in san diego on
may 25th in los angeles on may 22nd and
then the reschedule of foxwoods is june
25th also announcing these very soon so
they're not on sale yet but i want you
to pay attention new york city is coming
i'll be playing new york city may 14th
milwaukee minneapolis memphis louisville
evansville tulsa oklahoma city rochester
syracuse knoxville greenville hampton
beach and even more to be announced if
you heard your city i'll be announcing
this very soon just be on the lookout
all right guys savilecanoecomedy.com
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right hey taste buddies
welcome to monday welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buzz
so good to be back with you sweets yes
we're recording on a monday we are and
the episode just dropped a couple hours
ago it did and it's your
third episode back
first food battle back and the first
time you got heated is today yeah you
got i mean on the yeah
the one that posted today which is uh
sushi versus nachos yeah
and you got you get real heated in it
this will be next week so we're like
right up to speed yeah and and good news
this week and then next week again it's
definitely food two foods so um
i know the fans are excited and actually
i'm excited it was it helped us to drift
it helps us to drift away from it for a
bit yeah then circle back come back
reinvigorated passion for food but yeah
nachos versus sushi got got hot and
here's what's so funny and it's it's
it's just the way social media works
because it's social media and it's your
followers are writing to you usually
but like these i got you know i got
creamed in the battle yeah and then like
but then i go on today after the episode
post and everybody in my feed is like i
agree joe so she is king
all this stuff and then you get this
illusion
that far more people agree with you than
they do correct
because it's your feed it's your feed
right you know let's see if you got that
pimple you need help with anything
okay got it
i'm hot
you're hot yeah
well
i don't know what to tell you just body
temperature yeah
why i got a sweatshirt on i think about
taking it off it looks like a thin
sweatshirt it's heavy
what's kept nice what's kith
it's a brand cl uh streetwear clothing
brand classic nice sweatshirt thanks
yeah they charge it they charge you for
it though you pay for it what are you
paying for a kiss no i mean i don't know
they did old it all depends but i don't
know maybe no it was like i don't even
know like 150 bucks
i find these days it's hard to find a
sweatshirt that does not cost a hundred
dollars anymore is that right well you
should be hitting up our merch tour
pretty soon then yeah because we have 50
hoodies uh
for taste buds
and for
even i'm even doing solo hoodies
solo i'm doing solo merch solo merch
yeah actually pimp just get
pimp i just threw pimples sure yeah you
want you want it all right let me show
them but it's our our our actually and
our web store is up so i could show you
it like a version of it like what it's
going to look like and stuff they're
working on that great yeah this is a new
this is i mean we're going to have
that's a nice shirt we're gonna have
about five or six pieces for taste buds
is our stuff going to be on the same
shirt yeah we picked all different so
beautiful five i mean you did a product
downstairs has two boxes this i mean
boxes this big
like i mean they probably weigh about
40 pounds each okay
and they sent me
a version of every single company's
t-shirts sweatshirts hoodies everything
to go through to pick
the quality i like okay and i love this
quality i love it's got a little fade to
it it's it's a washed it's a faded
heavyweight watch talking my language
all right yeah all right so this is i
did uh what is this i might want to go
buy some of these now i got them for you
downstairs i'll give you some some
blanks yeah i got blank space shut up
swear shut up i had to
say take what you like out of it ship
the rest back so you could go you could
pillage it when before you leave buddy
i can't forget to do that because i'm in
need of teaser i'm your guy and when i
see a perfect tee i get very yeah well
you should also take one of my new
sav volcano okay god bless god bless
yeah street witch i love it i love it i
love it i like that [ __ ] that's great i
would wear that all day i got one for
you all day i got one for you i got one
for pimp all right they're gonna be
online soon i'm going to sell these at
my live shows but our store five or six
items hey babe five six items and my
souls are five six items all launching
momentarily we just had there's
manufacturing issues because there's
something called covet
pimping
you talking 19 why you talking 19. i
know it's it's 22. i know it's 22. cover
19 is like going into kindergarten i saw
somebody tweet it's junior year of covid
i think it's senior year i don't know
it's senior year dude covert 19 was
freshman year covert 20 was sophomore 21
is junior covet is graduating this year
where are you guys going to go to
college
[Laughter]
probably somewhere in florida texas
holy god it's a scene yeah i mean it's
uh wow wow we're in it we're in the
thick of it will covet 19
be gone
by the end of 22.
it's never gonna be gone
is there a thing to say
what's it called endemic it's an endemic
it'll never be gone but we'll will we be
living normal in the life by then tell
me when to stop
will we be living normal life by the end
of 2022 eight ball stop
most likely
but still most likely it's not a great
answer yeah eight ball didn't want to
commit
son of a meatball damn it all right
uh it's good to see you i'm having a
terrible day today
get out of town
why
you need to count your blessings more
let's count some blessings
good let's count blessings half the
power of my apartment is out okay that's
a blessing because you should all be out
full okay all right all right that's a
great point is yours out
half the po
yeah my apartment half oh i know you
said half in the building no so half of
your apartment is out no half of the
grit the grit the building got hidden
away where it like whenever the grids
are set up half of the building power is
out okay meaning like just certain stuff
in the build certain outlets and certain
things aren't working so like the
elevator doesn't work
um like my refrigerator went out my
stove went out but then like my living
room light works my tv can turn on okay
well would you rather would you rather
have your television or your uh fridge
i guess the television all right well
then things are coming up roses yeah
yeah yeah but
yeah yeah but i still lost whatever food
was in there i mean i'm talking tubs i
got tubs of jenny's ice cream and ben
and jerry's non-dairy yeah i mean
they're just gone we're talking
nine ten bucks
here's what you do here's what you do
yeah by the way they just they hit me up
for another six
so
jenny
oh did they yeah they didn't hit me up
no they didn't why not i don't know wait
they told you they didn't hit me up no
why are you laughing like you knew i was
just they didn't hit me up
they didn't why did i get hit
they said uh jenny come on
jenny jenny who can i turn to um jenny
was the one that hit me first
she jenny did hit you first yeah wait
where is it okay yeah yeah she they said
to me
jenny
uh
wanna help us set i might have missed a
date i didn't want to help us set a
world record for most people eating ice
cream for breakfast
we want to uh we want to set it on
national ice cream day which is saturday
february 5th we got a new flavor maple
soaked pancakes yeah i saw this and
because breakfast should be in pajamas
limited edition lounge shirt i had i
should have had my assistant get back to
this we'd love to send over both plus
our ice cream for breakfast collection
the week of 124. i missed it
all right
uh we did miss it all right uh well i
just promoted them so it's okay oh that
looks amazing yeah
all right uh oh what are you gonna do oh
my god that was so all right so let's
just count your blessings real quick you
have you have your health
i think
i'm not positive you have a career
yeah i gotta yeah yeah you have two
careers
you have three careers
you have four careers actually you have
acting podcasting comedy and you own a
business acting i don't count acting is
very rare you are on though i have a
very rare you're a recurring character
all on one of the best shows on
television
and i have a bigger dish tomorrow oh
what is it can we run the lines
on the show not on this we can't we
can't no oh okay you can't do
ndas oh okay auditioning tomorrow for uh
that show flatbush misdemeanors oh i
don't know i love it yeah yeah a lot of
my friends are kevin iso and yeah i
forget who writes kareem green's on it
great yeah
uh
yeah
what is it called flapper incidentally
misdemeanors the showtime show so i'm
auditioning for that tomorrow so we'll
see how it goes
perfect
what's your role what's your role
big surprise just he's an [ __ ]
you get there and they just change the
the the uh the sides and it just says as
the credits say as himself exactly
yeah i show up to set they're like we
don't need you to go to costume this is
a rant on somebody he needs a ransom no
i can't i can't say anything more than
that i just it's just it's a it's funny
but can't you though
no no no i can't i don't want to ruin it
uh but uh ruin the
well i if i if i don't want to ruin my
chances i still gotta didn't handle it
tomorrow this doesn't come out for a
week
i i shouldn't it's you know i i yeah
there's a there's a there's a respect
okay yeah okay
did you know your lines yet
no what do you do you sit home and you
read them over and over and you make
choices i make choices
i make choices i looked at this part and
i said i know do you want to i said i
know i'm channeling to do this oh you
channel yeah i'm gonna channel who do
you channel
i'm not gonna say can you channel people
how do you show people a channel how do
you channel intention
what's that person's intention
whose intention your character who
you're channeling yeah
wait wait wait
you would choose a person you know to
channel for a role for
is that what you're saying yeah so how
do you channel people can you channel me
like if i channeled you
right
you could channel me
if i if i were to channel you you
hearing this
i'm on the edge of my seat if i read a
part i if i read a part right
if i read a part uh that i was going to
audition for yeah and it was a guy that
would and it said like you know
nervous energy
you know whatever and i tried to channel
you the thing i would take away from you
and i go if i thought it related to you
right
i would go
okay this guy is sal
anything you throw at him he needs to
analyze it and consider it so that's
what's going on behind everything that
he is saying to you right now okay
anything that is getting tossed at him
in the scene he's he's digesting it he's
computing it he's with it that's what i
mean by like see so sometimes you can
see a thing and you go oh i get it he's
like a guy like this and in this
particular thing there was a guy i knew
and i was like i get what i get i think
i get it oh you know and i see if i get
it
well i know a lot of [ __ ] but but uh
this was a specific kind of [ __ ] but
do you know what i mean like if you were
going to channel me
yeah
you'd say
he's always pissed off about something
but how do i know
you in the scene like like let's say i
gotta like
do me a favor just tuck this in
channel me
channel me on the other end there and
tuck it in all the way please i can't
you understand move your body let's do
this i'm gonna i'll tell you what i have
ocd and it won't go away i'll tell you
what i'm gonna do please just tuck it in
as the one between us
that makes far less money i'm going to
buy you a new couch you got to get you
got to get past this couch everything's
this is absurd over here everything's
gucci just just no no you understand how
to do it joe just look at me look at me
look at me look at me just take it like
this and get in there and then go all
the way babe all the way but why do you
want to live like this
there it is
why do you want to live like this as
intended it's but i mean it's almost
like you you enjoy the the chaos of this
that you don't want to get i don't i
hate it i actually really hate it
actually every time that we recorded me
eucharist whatever
my ocd is off the charts lately but
there's a psychological study or studies
that have been done about people for
instance that watch like news that makes
them angry yeah or frightens them yeah
and they'll see that people will
continue to watch it because they become
addicted to i don't want to be that
reaction i hate it they skin crawls
that's what that's how they feel they
don't think they want to be addicted to
it but they're addicted to it i'm not
addicted to the velcro pieces of my
couch but i i in a way you are because
you have not replaced the couch
the couch has a substantial amount of
money it weighs a lot i'm not saying we
moved in here five years ago right uh
i'm not looking to replace the couch
because you know a couple times a month
you sit there and i hear the velcro's
come out i mean listen it's a nice
little couch the couch also does heavy
lifting
uh when the podcast is not around people
sleep on this couch it folds out into a
tempurpedic queen full-size mattress all
right i can understand that you might
not want to get rid of that
maybe you just cut these things off then
why do you need the velcro i'm going to
start cutting the cloth of the couch
no i just think there's a better way to
live than you have to tuck this thing
all the way maybe i'll write a stern
letter to the manufacturer i mean you
know this is this is no way listen
anyway back to channel it's the super
bowl is coming up this week no wait we
didn't finish channeling please channel
no no i i'm not channeling you your
channel okay
how do i channel you
if i so so i'm going to read something i
say oh i could see so let me ask you a
question though when you go to audition
and i only recently found this out like
yeah i'm not really let's put this one
oh sure
they're sometimes they're looking for
something specific sometimes they don't
know what they're looking for right and
if you come in and you do it a certain
way they're like oh that's that's good
that's good we didn't think of it that
way or i like that and i like that
they're two completely different takes
which one do you want more how often do
they actually be are they actually like
i know exactly what i want here and
they're like you're doing something
that's not whatever they're looking for
i do the opposite because i don't book
it
i don't know what direction they're
usually moving in well how did you get
on better call saul i auditioned it i
got it i've gotten a few things but why
but people are always like oh you're on
better call so you must get so much
acting work no it's not you know right
it's not like that that's like saying
like oh you uh you you opened for burr
at madison square garden that must have
led to so much stand-up work it's
medicine no it doesn't do anything it's
a nice experience i love i'm grateful
for it right for for these experiences
but but anyway it's always just starting
over from zero unless you're
you know it's like anything else the
more you do it the more right you know
but you get nervous on the auditions
no not at all not at all no
because it's not there are no stakes
what are you slate if i never acted ever
again it would not impact me in any way
slate slate to me right now i would like
to i'd be sad but i mean that's about it
what's that do you say i'm joe derosa
what do you do
6-2
zach friedman is my manager thank
you that kind of thing okay that kind of
thing and you ever do it and you go can
i take that again do you ever do that
yeah all the time you ask us i'll stop
sometimes don't go let's start over
i don't i feel like it's not in the
right groove like what do you
yeah what they don't mind
i don't give a [ __ ] if they do you say
you don't i okay so hearing me like the
problem you're going in not giving a
[ __ ] whatsoever and ordering them around
when they have to stop down and start
over i'm not ordering no they're they're
they're no they can't
cool casting director will be like yeah
okay sure what's what do you think i've
done a lot of self tapes for auditions
but when i go in for auditions
like it depends on what my schedule is
sometimes when i have a lack schedule
i'll tell my agents hey get me some
auditions and i'll go and audition i'm
auditioning for a bunch of [ __ ]
i don't remember if i got anything now
but you've gotten stuff just just
because which is great just because it's
a fun one that's a great one yeah one
time i went in to audition for the
irishman
oh wow yeah well it was three lines
right who cares but i went in and i it
was really simple but i think i was
still somehow underprepared because i
went in and it was martin scorsese's uh
this woman he uses to cast everything i
tell you this story no no and uh you
know it takes place i guess in the 60s
or whatever it is right so i like
slicked my hair a certain way he didn't
win a little extra
i went in
spoke to her a little bit and in the
scene robert de niro threatens me and i
piss my pants i'm like a low-level
bookie or whatever that okay
and uh she didn't make the movie it did
not yeah yeah and then uh so i did it
and
no no sorry sorry i get in there and she
starts talking to me
two ladies and she's like oh hey and i'm
like hey and she's like i was like how
did i get because i my agent didn't get
me the audition and she she told me a
friend of mine recommended me i was like
oh that's so cool and we started talking
and and she's like oh you know we're
talking for like three four minutes and
i was like you know i was actually i
actually pissed my pants on camera
before because of my because on the show
i did oh wow and so she's like oh how
and i tell her a little about it and
then all of a sudden she's talking to me
me sal and then she just goes
tell me and she just jumps into the oh
wow so the script and i just was like
i answered her and i was like and i was
like
like why wouldn't you just give me the i
didn't she didn't give me a heads up
she did fluster me yeah i can't she did
and then we took it over again and i was
so flustered i didn't do it the way that
i wanted to do it a little bit
and that was really the end of that was
that her testing your improv i i can
improvise like
she just went from talking to me and
then she just went launched right into
the lines and i was a little confused
if anything she befuddled me
and then i just didn't recover from it
and i just walked out like i didn't get
i think that's great
i think good
i do i think no no not that you didn't
get it that she works like yeah i think
good casting directors are as rare as
good anything like i i think i i i've
auditioned for a million things in my
life
and you can tell when they don't care
when they're not invested but when a
good casting director is there they do
they might try a technique like that
yeah they give you different angles to
see if you know how to take direction
okay they you know like when you go in
and they have you read it and go thanks
and you're just like
oh this is like a cattle call basically
like you're just waiting this you're
waiting for the guy to jump out that
just goes okay we don't have to do
anything i auditioned for the big sick
you know kumail's movie that won some i
think he might have won like a
screenwriting or nominee
for kurtz for kurtz
who was the best friend who i think had
to roll all along right and i went and i
was like why am i doing this when i saw
kirk gotta i was like i was never gonna
beat kurt for it yeah that's [ __ ]
funny yeah well they're really good in
fred's and real life right yeah
but wait back to channel sandler okay
channel
this is what i thought i was gonna get i
swear i talked about this on the pod
maybe it was a babe but um it was like a
movie he did like three four years ago
on netflix with chris rock about two
families it
it it was not one that was too popular
but
santa's the man like every time i've
seen him or gotten to talk to him or
grab a bite or something one time he's
always just the most coolest down to
earth he's a really nice guy like the
nicest guy ever the week of
yeah that was it okay so you haven't
even heard of it right no no i i
remember hearing about it it was about
like their daughter and son or getting
married or something anyway sandler's
the man the coolest guy ever we were we
were in nashville on on the same uh
comedy festival i went to go see his
show and he was performing with uh
schwartzen who i'm a friend friends with
spade who i know
and uh rob uh uh schneider schneider and
so i'm backstage actually ralphie was
back there miss ralph yeah but anyway so
so we're all hanging out and then sam's
like oh let's go out to eat or whatever
so i was like let's go he they had a
place stay open for him so we went out
we were the only like couple of tables
there all of his people from his all the
guys from the movies that he puts in all
of them is just so cool they were all
there we're hanging out stanley goes oh
you should be in uh should be in the
movie i'm doing right now he says and i
go
i gotta be honest i said you're gonna
have to sell me
and i said you know we'd love to be in
it like the guys too we're like we would
love to be in it yeah so he goes alright
cool cool and he goes yeah just i'll do
a roll whatever i was like cool
the next day
our agencies got the scripts
and it asked for us to audition which i
just thought we were gonna like i
thought he was just gonna throw me a
line or whatever
and so
it was i think maybe
my takeaway on it was it had to be a
formality like maybe he had to get us
through that process although he's
sandler so maybe not but he wouldn't
have said it if he didn't mean it and
the next day boom he had the scripts but
it was all for a role in the movie
that
was a little bit more substantial that i
didn't think that fit me at all and all
four of us read for the same role did
anybody get it no wow never heard from
him again so i thought that was odd wow
yeah you know what i i think you get
pranked more than you know
you think it was uh
your stories the cop the cop who didn't
help you with the car accident yeah yeah
i don't know man the pilot the pilot
yeah infectious disease
the uh but we didn't get it and i was
like that feels weird to me that he
didn't just like give us well i don't
i'm not old anything but the way he said
it was like be in the movie or whatever
and i thought look you guys
are capable of a little cameo you know
and then i read for this part and then
by the way i watched the movie and the
part i read for i would have never fit
that bill
so it just played it in the movie i
don't remember but it was like his
brother-in-law or something about ryan
gosling no no it was just not
us at all i don't know
um
listen i told you i may have a cameo in
the clerks iii yes that's very excited
about that yeah but you should stop
spilling all these beans on on air like
people
well the three auditions were in the
past and i didn't get them yeah i know
movies are out but you're clark street
that would have been a nice little
surprise kevin smith might have wanted
to easter egg oh i don't know
well i was gonna po i took a picture
with him on set i was gonna post that it
was my it was six months ago oh well i
don't know all right well i would have
loved to tell what i said i would have
loved not in clerks three two have been
in clerks three i would have loved to
have been in clerks free i mean i have a
couple of lines it's nothing no i know
but still like that's come on man that's
like i know yeah it's like to be in that
universe
yeah just now i can just say i'm part of
the universe yeah i know i know it's
pretty cool the uh we got a battle to do
but no i know but i just want to finish
the damn thought about channeling please
folks whether it's saving money and
spending less uh getting organized or
losing weight or you know just thinking
of whatever worthwhile goals that you're
trying to set for yourself for this
brand new year of 2022
at the top of many people's lists is
learning a new language that's where
babel comes in we love babble a language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions these fit these
lessons take about 15 minutes it's a
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go other language learning apps use
ai for lesson plans that's very
impersonal but babel lessons were
created by over a hundred language
experts uh the teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
yeah i mean here's how you used to learn
in school yeah they do this like it's
it's fun learning yeah uh 14 different
languages which we always talk about
including all the hits german italian
french spanish etc uh they have a speech
recognition technology that also helps
you with your pronunciation so not just
learning the context but the
pronunciation i think that's one of the
best features honestly well also in
addition to the lessons through babel
you can access podcasts games videos
stories and even live classes so there's
a host of things it comes with a 20 uh
20 day money back guarantee start your
new language learning journey today with
babel right now when you purchase a
three month babel subscription you're
gonna get an additional three months
free that's six months for the price of
three just go to babel.com and use our
promo code taste buds that's b a b b e l
dot com code taste buds babble language
for life
folks this podcast is sponsored by
better help and you know we've talked
t e r help
oh
let's do it again yeah
b-e-t-t-e-r help wow look at that we
adopted our chant and we gave it right
this is copywritten but we gave it right
to
betterhelp we love better health because
they're helping people that are having
things interfering with their happiness
or preventing people from achieving
their goals or whatever it is
we all have this i fight uh depression
and anxiety i go through it i get
seasonal depression uh i actually ditto
i get post new year's day depression
because i feel like the holiday season
is over
it's over and it's a long i'm getting
depressed on my birthday i get depressed
i get depressed every day okay uh what
is it what is it better help in case you
are don't watch this podcast or you
don't watch any podcast and you don't
know it's professional counseling it's
done online it's secure they match you
with someone that suits your needs you
can get in touch with you can touch them
within 48 hours from initially starting
you can message them anytime they have
experts from all fields and since you're
doing it online you're getting access to
people you might have not have access to
locally okay and this is the thing it's
not a crisis line it's not self-help
this is professional counseling i say it
all the time the daunting nature of
getting into counseling often prevents
people from getting the help that they
need or want and better help is helping
get rid of that laborious process
they've had over a million people uh
take charge of their mental health uh
and try it out um
anyway visit betterhelp.com tastebuds
that's better help and join over the one
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional special offer
for taste buds listeners get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com
taste buds that's b e d t e r help
please let's flip right back let's flip
it and i feel like i'm putting flip to
find a point on it okay i'm making it
sound bigger than it is okay maybe
channeling is not the right word but my
point is you thought you had a channel
let's not get any more you want to get
back the channel i am but you asked me
how you asked me how you what did i mean
how did it work yeah what i was going to
say is to say you had a line in a script
say my line was
well because we all know how you are and
you said what's that supposed to mean
that was your line okay right now my
line meaning your line you no you oh
okay that's the line okay but you're
channeling a guy like me oh okay so tell
me if i do it right what's my line
what's that supposed to okay so what do
you say
well we all know how you are
what's that supposed to mean see what i
mean
there you go that was you that's what
i'm saying you did it like a guy like
i'm gonna what i would do i'm gonna i'm
gonna
and then take it very personally
what's that supposed to mean you know
but then a guy like a guy like uh i'm
trying to think of uh like i would have
been like what's the line before it okay
i'll do you now are you ready and what
do i say we all know how you are oh we
all know how you are
what's that supposed to mean
that's how you would oh wow i think and
you don't know what they want going in
no so you just do your best ah
but you know what i mean like you see
this thing he's a curb
yeah you've seen the new season
they cast that young uh latina girl yeah
she's amazing and she misread every line
she's amazing how funny was it it was so
great seeing radinski in it too yes yes
yes queen shout out john shout out to
john rudnitz
shout out to elon gold it was good
seeing elon in there too
he played the head of hulu
oh yeah the guy i don't know him but
yeah using all the jewish words
that was really funny
uh anyway
super bowl is coming up this week and
you got the rams and you got the bangles
and super bowl sunday's craziest food
facts
1.25 billion chicken wings are eaten wow
that's almost one for every like
six and a half people on the planet
that's a lot 12.5 million pounds of
bacon that seems crazy 11.2 million
pounds of potato chips that seems insane
10 million pounds of ribs
8.2 million pounds of tortilla chips 2.8
million pounds of popcorn three million
pounds of nuts how do they get these
metrics
it seems it's just are they getting are
they getting like the um the amount of
of sales dividing it by the average
price per bag and looking at the weight
of the bag and then doing a multiplier
for instance pizza is the top snack for
super bowl and the re the way they
calculate that is the enormous number of
delivery orders on this
particular sunday so i guess they go by
stats like that uh they they look for
upticks in sales right like i mean yeah
but that's pretty specific like 12
million pounds of bacon all right one
out of every seven people
order in
on super bowl sunday and the majority of
those orders include at least one
sausage piece i'll tell you this sausage
is the third most popular pizza topping
overall i'll tell you this right now
before we get into the battle place
if i went to a super bowl party and they
were serving pizza i'd be pissed
i'd be pissed
that's what you're wrong
i'm not sure
let me you mean only pizza
no
pizza was one of the things they would
say no no i mean if pizza was the main
focus of the food at the super bowl like
chips pretzels blah blah blah pizza
pizza pizza not wings not exactly
exactly dude you go to a super bowl
party i want to see some i want to see
something the last few super bowl
parties yeah i didn't have pizza you're
right
yeah it's pizza's a is it is a
get-together and it's a great
get-together food but super bowl party
to me at a house is something a little
more special
i want to see you know i want cheeses
out i want some sliced meats i want some
subs some wings
some different things maybe some of
these things chili maybe yeah maybe a
chili potato skins maybe pigs in the
blanket maybe pigs in a blanket which is
our battle today
all right
we're doing a super bowl themed
battle
yes uh pigs in a blanket which is a
cocktail weenie if you didn't know that
versus
loaded potato skins yeah cheese bacon
sometimes a sour cream
chives baby that's your that's your
potato slice those chives up though i
don't ever usually have chives on mine
but sure i don't care if you want to
all right you ready with the skins on
still you know well that's why they're
called potato skins here we go
by the way this is one of the first
pieces of merch that is available this
shirt
no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you no matter
what i love you all right ready yeah
time to be a t t l e buds
people by the way are coming up to me in
public and doing that chanting my face
i'm not kidding really yeah how was
buffalo by the way
uh the shows were good uh it was seven
degrees and there was snow on the ground
but the staff was nice thank you helium
buffalo
uh thank you to everybody that came out
thank you to all the taste buddies that
came out did you meet any taste buddies
oh yeah i met some taste buddies had a
fun time did you yell anything out from
the are you on stage yes about
about taste buds yeah well tell us how
one of the one of the darker
shows i said uh one of the darkest oh no
i said i don't know if any of the i have
a podcast and then a bunch of people
cheered and they were like taste buds
and like and i was like yeah i don't
talk about any of that stuff
and then uh
i told a
i told a particularly dark joke that i
don't want to get into right now because
we try to keep the show clean okay
but it was it was dark
and after it i said i probably know the
joke i said uh
sal doesn't do this kind of a team
that's funny he's got a friendlier a
friendlier show but
i didn't mean that as an insult i just
read it like this is this is gold no one
wants to be eating
this stefano in a blanket
this one wins it already
but uh
but but uh
it was just it was just funny because i
was like because i and then i even said
i went farther and i said i go i worry
sometimes
that like the taste buds fans come to
the show and they think i'm going to be
like being like doing like an hour about
like cookies you should probably get get
a glimpse of who you are
yeah well i hope i don't go talk about
cookies either no i know but you still
have a you have a bubbly demeanor on
stage you're you because you're a bubbly
guy i'm not doom and gloom no but i'm a
doom and gloom guy that's coming in and
doing a bubbly a bubblier podcast
you're a bubbly guy that does a bubblier
podcast see what i'm saying right you
know if my if if like like let's put
this way when i was doing a news podcast
and people came to the show there was
not a point of
worry in my head that people weren't
getting what they thought they were
going to be
you know but
but i also know somebody told me um on
twitter yesterday that 98 of the
audience despises me it's always nice
when the fans write in
98.
that can't be right of course it's not
right
our boy hit us up with the new stats he
says apparently if a new season started
you saw these stats yeah if a new season
started
uh
when we said it was going to end like
the 52 right you saw that
okay if we if we finished it
at 52 episodes i was 29 24 and 1. you
were 24 29 in one the one tie being egg
salad versus tuna salad let's take a
little little little recap
uh
excel versus tuna salad the closest
battles ever
uh
were
fruit loops versus cocoa pebbles
lobster roll versus crab cake
s'mores versus rice krispie treats
tootsie pop versus blow pop
you picked a great time to do this
right after we launch into the
all right you're right the battle uh all
i'm saying is you lost the first season
just would momentum and the current
the current new stats what a great recap
yeah
jesus christ what are you doing man you
losing your [ __ ] over there
the new stats you have to starting at
episode 60 i'm 2-0
you're on two
okay
[Music]
so what do we get to do i wanted to have
something i wanted to mean something
it's not the time to discuss it right
now
why don't we talk about merch while
we're here what do you think i think we
should change that one t-shirt okay the
merch is gonna be i'm joking i'm not
joking i know i'm just gonna take the
joke further
don't let's battle it's like two classic
starter caps one says b-a-t-t-l-e buds
another one says the god damn and girl
scouts we have one shirt that says no
matter what happens i love you the words
make up a heart and in the middle it
says n
and the initials h-i-l-y
we have one with me and you as like uh
almost like almost like nba jam
characters old uh nba big head shirts
cartoons
and we're in like a knicks uniforms yep
we have one that is like those
spray-painted like hip-hop slash
like uh
boardwalk beach shirts where they spray
paint and it says they come into the mic
taste whether you have that coming out
we have shoelaces that say no matter
what happens i love you coming out
i think we got some stickers coming
and a sweatshirt and so on and so forth
and the sweatshirt that's the sweatshirt
that says they come into the mic and
it's it's in okay spray painted great
old-school hip-hop hip-hop vibes yeah
okay great all right so there we go all
right
folks
pigs in a blanket
i'm pigs in a blanket i know obviously
yeah i know right and you you pick
potato skins what are just a dumb choice
just what a dumb choice i don't think
it's excited here's why potato skins
suck
uh and i do like them but here's why
they suck
nine times out of ten with a potato skin
it's you get excited you're like look at
that cheesy potato with bacon bits and
then you bite into it and it is way too
much potato on top of that skin
the cheese is getting dry the flavor of
the bacon and everything gets lost to
the amount of potato disagree completely
and it ends up just being something that
you have to dunk repeatedly into sour
cream to be able to choke it down it's a
half a potato i think they pack a wallop
i think they're nice and substantial for
an hors d'oeuvre or a cocktail treat i
think they're not as common as pigs in a
blanket there's certainly more
if you can even call it upscale than
pigs in a blanket pigs in a blanket is
the baltic avenue of the hors d'oeuvre
of the hors d'oeuvre now it is the
baltic mediterranean it is the
it is as soon as you pass go you're
getting served buddy it's the cartoon
place you go you go to your high-end
functions
you go to your high-end functions you're
going to make a picture
immediately you're going to say you've
got pigs in a blanket
you go to your heart it's the two before
go not the two you could go high-end you
go to a high-end hollywood party i
promise you two things you will see on
those hors d'oeuvre trays pigs in a
blanket mini crab cakes they are the
staple high-end hollywood party who the
[ __ ] are you like if you go to like an
empty first of all like an emmy's part
okay right right because that's what
they're going to relate to guys you all
know the pigs are the black people and
the number one thing served at the emmy
party i'm just saying they're not
they're not low rent first of all we're
talking super bowl snack okay
anything a potato skin is more more
super bowl snack than a cocktail weenie
dude it's a cocktail weenie meant for a
cocktail party
packtail is in the name cocktail winning
you're saying it's a low-rent snack
cocktail potty tail party that is park
place baby that is not
you get cocktail weenie one of two ways
it's a past hors d'oeuvre which by the
way if you're passing that hors d'oeuvre
we're nowhere fancy number two you get
it just if you wait if you stack of
about a thousand
dollars
hold on a second hold on a second what
do you mean it's a past hors d'oeuvre
what's that mean it's passed someone
walks around with it all hors d'oeuvres
are passed
not necessarily also plenty of people
put cocktail wheaties out on a big
platter with a
mustard dip that was the second thing i
just said yeah i just decided not to
listen so how are you what's the
difference between that and potato skins
being out on a tray
i wasn't arguing them being out on the
tray i'm just saying that you said a
past hors d'oeuvre cannot be parked
place well well then what hors d'oeuvre
is park place i didn't say a past hors
d'oeuvre cannot be what did you just say
i just said that a cocktail weenie is
not park place then what is park place
so the hors d'oeuvre family although
derv family party orders gotta be like
uh party hors d'oeuvres
yeah it's gotta be up there it's gotta
be like a shrimp cocktail a pate
what do you call that [ __ ] uh caviar i
passed hors d'oeuvre on broadway you're
you're comparing caviar to cocktail
but you think somehow uh uh potato skins
are higher up they're doing it right now
cocktail weenie right now for me
cocktail weenie 250 i'm putting a hotel
on it 250
you want to put a whole 75.
you got to get you got to get better you
got to raise 20 minutes i got news for
you potato skins are lower than the hot
dogs no they're not potato skins potato
skins that you're getting up there
potatoes it's a new york avenue
oh so you're so insane right now
nothing on new york avenue comes in a
frozen box with tgi fridays written on
it nothing yes it does nothing i think
you start getting rid of frozen foods
when you pass free park no when you pass
go to jail go to directly to jail when
you pass the cop there's you're gonna
stop breaking out of there's your frozen
there's your fancy potato skin that's
just cause tj for tga friday sells it
frozen i mean people sell freaking
lobster frozen what does it matter that
is the leading brand of frozen potato
skins in the supermarkets the one i
always see everywhere i want you to pull
up the leading brand of pigs in a
blanket and let's just let's just see
where the class comes in the frozen kind
bro joe you can't possibly be sitting
here trying to argue class for a
cocktail weenie oh i'll argue at all
first of all the cocktail hebrew nash
i'm already passionate the cocktail
weenie is good
but it's i like that you could pop them
in your mouth i like that the uh there's
a pastry wrapping instead of like a
breading wrapping i like the pastry
wrapping it's a great combination okay a
lot of times they're either under done
or overdone and a lot of times they're
cold if you don't get them as soon as
they come out and one unlike those
potato skins that you know that that
stay piping hot but a cocktail weenie is
just all you're eating is a hot dog over
and over and over and over pastry that's
like saying with peanut butter jelly all
you're eating is peanut butter and jelly
no it's the combination of factors that
becomes incredible a cocktail weenie
also has no depth
what a potato skin is taking you on a
ride
okay
think about your your palate and what
you're what what taste what a potato
skin is hitting on you're hitting on
some crispy bacon you're hitting on a
really nice melted cheese you're hitting
on a nice
nice browned potato with a great crispy
skin underneath yeah a dollop of sour
cream for a little texture and and and a
little cold with the heat original and
then some nice chopped fresh chocolate
yes originally invented two or three
bites originally invented as a way to
turn a potato peel into a profitable
meal they took garbage and figured out a
way to make it edible and the one of
three restaurant chains is credited as
inventing it tgi fridays is one of the
chains you animal i don't care you're a
pig in a blanket if i never found out
where it came from i wouldn't change my
mind about where what i feel about it i
don't care that it comes from there let
me tell you guys you could make you
could do anything so i could challenge a
michelin star chef to make me their
version of a potato skin it doesn't
matter promise you i promise you i
promise you i promise you i promise you
and we can even try googling it if you
went to a a fancy chef or celebrity chef
a michelin chef whatever you want to
call it right but an astute chef and you
said what would you prefer to make me a
gourmet pig in a blanket or a gourmet
potato skin they will pick pig and
blanket why because it involves creating
a flaky pastry
it involves creating a great sausage of
some kind that is that is a great they
would do the same thing with with a
potato skin
what could you do sal it's cheese bacon
and potato you can put
that's what it is
a pig in a blanket is a hot dog or a
sausage
okay how is that any different you could
put a pancetta on there you could bacon
is baking different type of cheese bacon
is bacon let's just leave it there bacon
is basically a hot dog is a hot dog no
yeah no that [ __ ] always you can put
parts
sweet italian sausage you could put a
hot spicy sauce in a blanket you could
put
there's no chef redoing it that's what i
just said buddy that's what i just said
honestly you can go
to a restaurant and get a potato skin
you're buying pigs in a blanket out of a
sack of frozen pigs in a blanket when
you go to anywhere and they're serving
pigs in a blanket you think they are
cooking dude there is this big things of
them and then wrapped in there's nothing
more exciting than when you go into a
party and you see that platter of pigs
in a blanket how many can you it's so
exciting is it really yes
i'll tell you this
i'll tell you
h-e-l-l-o
fresh
[Laughter]
doesn't work as good it works
boy we love hello fresh baby
i love how hellofresh is a food delivery
service pre-portioned ingredients
seasonal recipes delivered to your door
uh you don't have to go to the grocery
store you save money hello fresh is
america's number one meal kit it's
cooking it makes cooking easy fun and
affordable we uh we touted all the time
on this podcast uh they deliver
pre-portioned ingredients to your door
farm fresh produce it arrives within a
week um they have a fit and wholesome
recipe section for satisfying uh with
nutritious meals uh you can feel good uh
with about six recipes per week to
choose from including low calorie and
low carb conscious options and customize
your dishes uh
what's that baby you're gonna say i was
i was what i like about hellofresh is
and you know this relates to a lot of
the stuff we're talking about that's
that to sponsor us products or whatnot
it sees it's it's a seasonal thing this
lifestyle whatever and a lot of people
get seasonal depression especially if
you live in a cold area
and if you live in a cold area and
you're not feeling so motivated your
tendency is to start to eat unhealthy
you start to eat according to that i
live in alaska yeah
folks but you start to overdo it with
the comfort foods yeah and one of the
things i like about hello fresh is
they're saying look man we're going to
get you the same level of deliciousness
the same enjoyment out of the meal the
same amount of time as any of those
meals you might want to indulge in
except it's going to be fit and healthy
and decent for you that's an amazing
thing that that took for them to offer
that with this convenience i believe
this might be something new too correct
me if i'm wrong but they they do a new
thing called hello custom and you could
swap out uh one protein for another or
upgrade it so you could add more protein
to a veggie meal so more choices more
variety that you can tailor to you also
there are 20 minute and 30 minute
recipes great so you can make that whole
meal tonight in 20 minutes if you want a
hellofresh is 72 percent cheaper than a
restaurant meal of the same quality how
good is that you can save on average uh
over 65 per month when you order
hellofresh instead of grocery shopping
get me to the bottom of that pimpy i
love it okay go to hellofresh.com slash
tastebuds one six that's 16 the number
and use taste uh use code tastebuds 16
for up to 16 free meals and three free
gifts bestseller and the biz uh that's
hellofresh.com tastebud16 use code
tastebud16 for up to 16 free meals and
three free gifts america's
is america's number one meal kit that's
right uh we're in 2022
things are finally starting to settle a
bit we're getting our footing in the
year i am a new business owner
this podcast in and of itself is a new
business in theory right this channel on
youtube is a new business and business i
will say
is off to a good start so far and we
appreciate it this is booming online
shopping especially and that's where
shipstation comes in because they're a
company that are going to help you get
your business off to a good start and
maintain
the that at that level it's here's if
you are shipping it's it's a one-stop
shop it handles all the shipping needs
it's quick it's affordable completely
painless they are already trusted by
over a hundred thousand e-commerce
sellers keep track of your orders from
any sales channel uh find the best
shipping carrier with the best deeply
discounted rates automate any shipping
task with just a few clicks uh what i
love the most about ship station is that
the the hardest part of starting any
sort of business is the little stuff
that falls through the cracks and one of
the things that can easily fall through
the cracks on you is not paying
attention to what your output in
spending is with things that seem
irrelevant or not expensive in one fell
swoop right
shipping is not a big buy all at once
it's money that adds up in smaller
increments and then also not getting to
the post office that's the big one for
me because automating everything from
home yeah that's great so the fact that
they're letting you not only find the
best prices but also let you do this
remote it's it's just you're saving time
you're saving money and you're saving
sanity make shipping the easiest part of
having an online store you have bigger
ideas to think about so here's what we
want you to do
you're gonna ship more in less time with
ship station we want you to use our
offer code taste buds to get a free
60-day trial that's two months free of
no hassle stress free shipping
shipstation.com
sorry go to shipstation.com uh click on
the microphone at the top of the page
and type in taste buds ship station make
ship happen
you know what i've seen on some of the
the
high end is not the term i would use but
some of the kitsch not kitschy is the
wrong term too but some of the um why
don't you use the right term i'm trying
to but you got me flustered right now
all right but somebody
uh you go into one of these like
cocktail suave like sort of hip soirees
uh neighborhood spots you know what i
mean that that have a very limited menu
and like craft cocktails and that kind
of thing like a kind of swanky or
whatever swank is the word i would use
okay um
i've seen on those menus on their
appetizer menu pigs in a blanket
ironically
it's not ironic it's taking something
and elevating it because it's able to be
elevated for the same reason you see
deviled eggs on those menus a lot i
can't believe i've never seen potato
skins i've ever believed you sat down
here and you were trying to make a class
argument for the cocktail weenie it's
called a pig
in a blanket yeah pork yeah oh sorry
potato skins it's disgusting sounding
it's disgusting the potato has skin on
it yeah and a pig is pork what's your
point and the pastry is a blanket yeah
it's called the pig in a blanket joe you
can't argue upscale come on i i will
argue that it's more upscale than the
goddamn potatoes one note babe it's one
note how many
i dip it into some mustard on the second
bite it's it's not one no sorry what did
you just say i said i dip it into
mustard on the second one what did you
go to the first bite i bite it
then i go to mustard for the second bite
see you're a pig
what you're biting it and then you're
dipping it in the mustard not a
community mustard i put a little on my
own plate
you didn't say that oh [ __ ] you
sal at the last super bowl party did you
see him with his own dip he's seen me
with a million dips i've never dipped
twice ever ever he probably double dips
he probably double dips i'll keep an eye
on her from now on you're telling me
that you make your own mustard from
their other mustard i pick up one of the
little plates made available at any
decent party spread and i take a
disposable spoon and i scoop some of my
own mustard into this thing and i think
one of the little breaks made available
if i were to dip after i bit i flip it
and go un-bit end into the dip okay well
that's what you should be doing you want
a cookie for it is that legal though
with covert is that legal i know i don't
even know well this is all pre-covered i
haven't been to a super bowl party in
six years at this point
joe
a cocktail weenie is is look it has its
place i like him but it is that's what
that's what's going on by the way that's
what the whites used to say about all
other uh races in this country they have
their place
god don't do that don't project
you made it about race and class
yeah all you gotta do is uh mention
mcdonald's and you got the joe rederos
of trifecta
wait
but it's bottom of the barrel stuff the
cocktail weenie uh it's okay they're
serving potato skins at fast food
restaurants sometimes what do you think
they can't even serve cocktail weenies
at fast food restaurants buddy buddy
you're the crux of your argument the
crux of your auntie anne's argument was
that goddamn pretzel dog why because
it's amazing that's because it's wrapped
in anti-ann's greatest
hey listen to me
blanket can't be a mini pretzel dog
because i've seen those too my cousin
has a pretzel shop she sells splatters
on a mini presentation
would you run out of the oxygen
listen to me we
we based this argument on let's just
call the parameters of a super bowl
party what would i rather see at a super
bowl party i think i'm rather going
tater skins
okay babe they just they just have depth
they got a little substance there's a
lot going on there's not a lot going on
they're less common
i i appreciate them more
but if i saw if i saw a platter of
150 little cocktail weenies piled on top
of each other would it would have would
have a jar of mustard next to it and i
saw a tray of
jar mustard you put it in a serving bowl
stop the stop downgrading the way
whatever food is present you put in a
tiffany serving bowl i don't give a [ __ ]
all right okay yeah and i and i see a
piping hot plate of potato skins i'm
going potato skins
let's let's
what are you eating first let me bring
another thing into this
sour cream is your is your dress up i
love it i love it too sour cream the big
j okra okrason of foods
why
i don't get it because it just is just
jersey as jersey cups
sour cream
like you
i love sour cream i love it too you know
who else loves it what big jokers all
right
cocktail weenie a dijon mustard what are
we uh hold on hold on what are we
talking about let me let me set up a
hypothetical for you okay
you come to a gathering okay there's
only
cocktail weenies only
that's it
you leave you eat you leave you eat you
leave you know whatever only cocktails
come from there all day you come to
another party there's only
potato skins
you leave
when you tell somebody about the party
which one are you railing harder on
potato skins not true that's you're
lying to me you're looking i'm not lying
to you why cocktail weenies are my
favorite party appetizer or hors
d'oeuvre whatever word you want to give
it they're my favorite of all time i get
genuinely excited i will buy sometimes a
box of cocktail weenies and make them
and eat them by myself
can you snip that and you i need that i
need that clip please
what do you just put on a little like uh
cocktail music you walk around the house
with a toothpick i walk around the house
i put on a black and white uh like sort
of made
french and i have a night by myself but
now i'm telling you i get i love pigs
and blind i've loved them somebody said
earlier on here pigs and blanket are the
uh snack of a loving mother potato skins
are snack from a drunk frat boy which i
agree i mean that is i mean literally
literally reverse that no yes potato
skins are a treat from a loving mother
frat boys eat cocktail weenies give me a
break
give me a break
look at this this lady doesn't even know
what it is go back up pimp just no no
right there i'd rather eat potato skin
than animal skin wrapped around mystery
meat what does that even mean it's not
animal skin wrapped around well i guess
the skin of a hot dog is oh give the
skin of a hot dog is animal skin wrapped
around mystery meat which is the center
of the hot dog she knows what she's
talking about no one and i repeat no one
wants a little wiener in their hand
that's funny uh
okay what about this they've been out a
while
okay good they've been out a while what
tastes better after they've been out of
water without a doubt pigs in a blanket
i disagree dude potato skins first of
all you like to make this this argument
sometimes potato skins are for old
people i agree
uh
but you like to make this argument where
you go if you don't get it right out of
the oven they get cold that's how all
food works sal that's not what i said
you said it earlier you said it a lot of
times you'll get them right out of the
oven they're cold well they do get cold
quickly
any food gets cold quick that's how food
works now if i take a potato skin out
out of the oven
and pick it up i gotta do the exact same
time no the potato skin is more dense
it's holding heat longer for sure for
sure it's it's a potato skin when a
potato skin gets cold it becomes an
unedible it tastes like you're eating a
raw potato that has plastic cheese on
top you're being sold you're being sold
shaking his head yes the cocktail is
being sold to bill of goods
it's it's it's it's trash joe it comes
they they come only frozen they they
just it's just nothing to it as opposed
to what only frozen as opposed to what
as opposed to the potato skins people
make potato skins people make things my
mom used to make her own pigs in a
blanket you get the croissant the
pillsbury croissant thing and you make
them it's not hard to do it's just the
same bite over and over and over
if i'm comparing how is potato skin not
the same bite over and over it's potato
cheese
bacon if you're lucky you keep leaving
out the chives and it's like one of my
favorites i i got i got news for you bob
i've had chives on top of potato skins i
can't even taste the chive it's just
something that sort of crunches it's
almost like having lettuce on top of it
it's adding no flavor i'm sorry that
your palate is not distinct enough for
the shot oh man all right well listen we
got to go
we got to go to the to the votes right
pimpy yeah yeah i'm just i don't know
dude
i don't know huh
it's called pigs in a blanket it doesn't
matter and you're talking class doesn't
matter well only because you're putting
your
[ __ ] food above my food how dare you you
go to a nice bar and grill you saddle up
at the bar you order a nice cold pint of
beer
watching a game you're watching your
soaps whatever you're watching
they drop a plate of piping hot potato
skins in front of you or a tray of mic
little weenies which one do you want
don't you dare say microwave don't you
dare no i'm saying micro but like little
weenies i'm excited
for the i'm more excited for the pigs
and blanket do i like a potato skin yes
i am telling you what happens every time
i go oh [ __ ] potato skins i bite it and
i go this tastes like a lot of potato
and very little of the part i wanted
which was the cheese and the bacon and
now i have to dunk this repeatedly over
and over in sour cream and now this has
just become a vehicle to move oh this
new jersey into my mouth it's one that's
it so i like i like the potato skin
because it combines everything in a
single bite everything is loaded on top
of that same bite over and over same but
as you're saying the bite has the bite
has layers to it has depth there's so
many different there's there is there's
different consistencies it's crunchy
it's it's it's soft it has it's creamy
it's got a little crisp with the chives
and the bacon it's me it has melted
cheese it's a lot going on it's complex
a pig in a blanket is not complex dude
all right it's again it's not bad but i
don't think it's beating a potato skin
somebody said chris in a blanket is
something i would like to consume
uh piggy's babe i know joe will get mad
but come on who pass up chris chrissy d
in a blanket i'm not mad at all it's a
team i'm on
piggy in a blanket scroll up one sec my
mom calls pigs in a blanket jesus in a
blanket and we used to eat them at
christmas time
that's so weird that's weird that's a
contender for the win that's so weird
all right
wonder how many responders will consider
the word party when casting their vote
it's pigs all day babe
this is a good battle potato skins don't
get me wrong i love the pibs but i don't
need to be reminded that's exactly what
i am when i'm scuffing down sausages
wrapped in bacon on a cold day
wait
again sausages wrapped in bacon it's not
a pig in a blanket what man is what old
man is picking potato skins
uh keep going down
let's go up a little bit potatoes remind
me of my white
teach
my white
teach
midwestern childhood
sitting around the dinner table clogging
our arteries good memories
finally an even battle potato skins are
dry it can only be helped with sour
cream pigs in a blanket not only bring
my mouth joy but the name is fun great
point
pigs in a blanket is like an electric
blanket on a frigid new york morning in
february it's like a [ __ ] hug
contrastly nobody ever peels the
potatoes right the potatoes are always
undercooked or overcooked and just
because there's toppings doesn't mean no
salt i'm not expecting points
versus a tray of undercooked potato
skins you had one time but he's i'm
telling you to judge it at the moment
no but you can't do that because we
always argue the merit of the dishes
most of the time it's not good
that's the point picking a blanket
american classic potato skins is
communist uh it looks like i might get i
mean i might get demolished here
shout out to the potato skin little
literal trash that has been fashioned
itself into a staple appetizer all right
that's actually a guy in a blanket you
can grab a handful shake them all around
in your hand in there
funny josh funny john decker finish
gives you use pop one in your mouth as
you walk around potato skins are usually
dry and you're trying to talk with
partially chewed potato in your teeth
who are you doing let's give john let's
give john the retweet uh follow john at
nurse j 1973 and let's also retweet
the the jesus in a blanket one that was
so odd man like i just want to give it
some some uh
some light well i can tell you right now
according to these comments it looks
like i'm i'm in for an 80 20 drubbing
also follow at maddie m-a-d-d-i-e
all right gang uh okay here we go uh
it's time for a little humble pie let's
get a drum roll only seven thousand
votes
yeah they they changed the algorithm now
that we don't get that like we used in a
half hour we don't get used to get about
double that at least yeah by the end of
the day we get 50 000 but you ready yeah
you got any plugs before we do this
because we got to wrap you know
yeah i got plugs uh i already plugged
our shows at the top all right on march
11th i'm playing the ryman in nashville
march 12th i'm playing devoli tivoli
theater in chattanooga
i am about to start playing new i might
be playing new york city on may 14th
a very special place that i will
announce soon and everything else is
still on sale detroit and pittsburgh uh
we just did right because this is next
monday detroit and pittsburgh thanks for
coming out those are four great sold out
shows
i'm hoping uh
joe derosa info for all my upcoming
shows i got austin coming up soon i have
uh philadelphia coming up soon i believe
i'm going to be at south by southwest so
i'll also be in uh a comedy fort in june
so come out and see me at one of those
gigs and then of course joey rose's bar
and sandwich shop yeah 174 rivington
street babe
joeyrosesnyc.com love it and i just
gotta i just got a shout out albany
because we're trying to sell a second
show dc
madison and chicago trying to sell out
those second shows so if you guys are
listening don't wait any longer here we
go salvolcano county.com for the tickets
better party appetizer
pimp is choosing pig's gonna be
still close way closer than we thought
did not reflect the uh the commentary
finally that score joey gets a win under
his mouth
53.9
pigs in a blanket to 46.1 potato skins
wow okay i thought i was gonna get
slaughtered that's actually a it's under
four percent margin recall under five
percent rematch margins which by the way
why don't we ask the the people what
they want to see rematched more than
anything else it has to have been under
a five percent deficit but let us know
where you want to see the first big
rematch going okay and the only thing
that was a dead dead dead-on tie was egg
salad tuna salad right
folks
wow congrats to you babe thanks buddy i
still love you i love you too
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right